Usually when we talk about intelligence, we rely on this very specific, very comfortable metaphor.
Right. The whole brain is a computer thing.
Exactly. We imagine the human brain is essentially a biological computer. Like there is the hardware, the wetware of the brain itself locked away up there in the dark vault of the skull. And then there is the software.
The mind.
Yeah, the mind, the complex code of intelligence running on top of it. And in this metaphor, your physical body is basically just, well, a meat vehicle. It's the keyboard, the mouse, and the monitor. It types in the inputs. It displays the outputs. But the real
serious thinking is happening purely upstairs, completely separate from your physical form.
It is it's an incredibly pervasive way of looking at ourselves. I mean, it permeates our culture, our education systems and historically a lot of cognitive science, too. We like to think of our minds as these pristine, isolated calculation engines that just happen to be
driving a flesh and bone car.
Right. But what if that entire metaphor is fundamentally backwards? What if intelligence isn't just a software program that happens to be decorated by having a physical body?
Which is a huge paradigm shift.
It really is. What if human intelligence is actually constituted by having a physical body? So today we are taking a deep dive into a radical framework called the embodiment hypothesis. And we are doing it by looking at the ultimate
unparalleled learning machines on the planet, human babies.
Yeah. And specifically, we are anchoring this discussion on a highly influential 2005 paper by Linda Smith and Michael Gasser. It's titled The Development of Embodied Cognition, Six Lessons from Babies.
Such a great paper.
It really is a brilliant distillation of the intellectual lineage behind the embodiment hypothesis. It argues with a lot of empirical evidence, you know, that starting out physically grounded in a messy, chaotic, three-dimensional world isn't a limitation we have to overcome. It's
actually the secret sauce to human intelligence.
Okay, let's unpack this. Because if this paper is right, it flips everything you think you know about learning completely upside down. We are going to extract the critical insights from this research, starting with the very first way a physical body
interacts with the world, which is through our senses.
Right.
Now, the standard operating theory for most people is that our five senses are completely separate data streams like vision goes to the brain's vision department. Touch goes to the touch department. Hearing goes to audio.
They process separately and maybe compare notes later. Yeah,
exactly.
Well, that's the intuition. But the reality of our experience is profoundly multimodal from day one. Those sensory streams aren't isolated at all. The paper introduces a concept here called degeneracy.
Yeah.
Now, in cognitive science, degeneracy isn't a bad word. It refers to a structural redundancy in the brain. It means that any single concept you have, like your concept of space, can be built and triggered by multiple completely different configurations
of neural signals.
Oh, interesting. Give me an example of that. Like, how does redundancy actually build a concept?
Well, think about how you understand the physical space of a room. You understand it by seeing the wall, sure. But if the lights go out, your concept of that space doesn't just vanish.
Oh, right, because you can hear the room.
Exactly. You can hear how your footsteps echo differently if you're in a tiny closet versus a grand hall. You can feel the air currents. You can physically reach out and bump into a chair.
Yeah.
Because of this degeneracy, if a baby is born completely blind, their foundational concept of space isn't wiped out. It just develops robustly through a different cluster of modalities, touch, sound, physical movement.
I follow that. I mean, having multiple roads to the same destination makes the system resilient. But the paper also talks about a second concept called reentry, which seems to suggest these senses are doing more than just providing backup for one another.
Yes, reentry is where the embodiment hypothesis really takes off. Reentry is the mechanism where our different sensory systems are constantly, relentlessly educating each other in real time and without any external teacher telling them what to do.
So how does that work?
Imagine a baby holding a plastic block. They see the block, they feel its hard edges, and they feel the tension in their own arm muscles holding it up.
OK, so they have three completely separate streams of data happening at once.
Exactly. But they are critically time-locked. As the baby's hand moves the block to the left, the visual input of the block moves to the left at the exact same millisecond. Oh, wow. The sight and the feeling are perfectly correlated in real time. Because of
that perfect temporal overlap, those independent neural mappings wire together. The motor action of the hand literally teaches the visual cortex what it is looking at.
Honestly, I'm struggling to wrap my head around this. You're saying the visual cortex and the motor cortex are essentially wiring themselves together just because the events happen at the exact same millisecond? Yes. How does that not result in a completely jumbled cognitive
mess? I mean, the world is full of simultaneous, totally unrelated events.
Well, because the baby's own body is the filter. When a baby generates the movement themselves, the correlation is absolute. The paper highlights a brilliant example of this using something that completely breaks our standard sensory rules, which is transparency.
Oh, like glass.
Right. Think about a glass window or a clear plastic box. To a developing brain, transparency is a total paradox. The eyes are looking at it and saying, hey, I see the toy. This is empty space. Just reach right on through. But the hand smacks into it and says, nope, solid
wall.
It's like a glitch in the matrix for a baby. The visual data and the tactile data are suddenly in direct conflict.
Exactly. And the paper details this fascinating study, the diamond transparent box task. If you hide a toy inside a box that has an opening on one side, nine-month-old babies are actually much better at getting the toy out if the box is opaque, like made of
cardboard.
Wait, really? What if it's clear?
If the box is transparent plastic, they fail miserably. They just keep trying to reach directly through the solid, clear plastic because their eyes are totally hijacking the system.
So how do they learn to fix the glitch? Because obviously adults know how glass works. We don't just walk into windows all day. Well, usually.
Right. Another group of researchers, Titzer, Thalen, and Smith, tried a very simple intervention. They didn't try to teach babies about glass. They just gave eight-month-old babies a bunch of transparent plastic buckets to play with at home.
Just normal buckets?
Yeah. No instructions, just let them bang him around in the living room for a few weeks. And by the time those babies turned nine months old, they completely crushed the transparent box test in the lab. They easily navigated to the openings.
Because by just randomly banging those clear buckets around on the floor, their physical hands literally taught their eyes how to see transparency.
Exactly.
Okay. Imagine a team of blindfolded people trying to describe an elephant. If they're all just touching different parts and never communicating, they'll never figure out it's an elephant. But in the human brain, those blindfolded people, our senses, are constantly
talking to each other. The hand tells the eye, hey, I know you think this is empty space, but I'm hitting something. See that subtle glare? When you see that glare, expect a solid surface. Does this mean visual recognition is actually speaking the internal
language of physical action?
That is exactly the mechanism. The physical action calibrates the visual perception. And what's wild is that this isn't just a baby thing. This carries into adulthood.
Oh, really?
Yeah. The paper mentions a visual test by Tucker and Ellis. They brought adults into a lab, sat them in front of a computer screen, and showed them pictures of objects. For example, a water pitcher. The adults just had to quickly press a button to say, yes, that is a pitcher, or no, it isn't.
Purely visual recognition.
Sounds incredibly simple. Just look at the screen and identify the shape.
But here's the catch. The adults were significantly faster to hit the yes button if that button happened to be on the same side of their body as the handle of the picture on the screen.
Wait, hold on. You're saying my ability to visually recognize a picture on a flat screen is tied to where my physical hands are resting on the desk. That sounds like a stretch. It's just a picture of a pitcher.
It sounds bizarre until you realize that your concept of a picture isn't just visual. Seeing the handle on the right side of the screen actually primed the motor response of the subject's right hand to physically reach for it.
No way.
Think about this right now as you are listening. If you are looking at a cocky mug on your desk, your brain isn't just analyzing its color and geometry. Your motor cortex is literally simulating the act of grabbing the handle. You are physically interacting with it just
by perceiving it. Visual recognition is built out of and continually educated by its time-locked connections with physical action.
Here's where it gets really interesting, because if our minds are entirely built on physical action, what happens when the physical capabilities of the body suddenly level up? Because babies change rapidly.
This is a crucial point. The paper argues that babies aren't smart at the start, and that profound lack of ability is actually a massive evolutionary advantage.
How so?
Well, human infants are born incredibly premature compared to, say, a horse or a cow, which can walk hours after birth. But this systematic restriction of physical ability restricts the sensory input. A newborn is mostly just looking and listening.
That limits the data and organizes their initial attention.
Oh, that makes sense.
Then they gain neck control. Then they learn to sit and reach. And a whole new flood of multimodal data comes in. The data is incrementally revealed as the body physically grows.
And the craziest part of this paper is reading about how changing the body's physical geometry actually cures cognitive errors. There's this classic developmental test discussed in the paper called the A-not-B error.
Oh, yeah. That's a famous one.
It works like this. You take an eight-month-old baby. You hide a toy under a blanket at location A. You do this a few times, and the baby successfully reaches out and finds
it.
Then, right in front of them, making sure they were watching you, you hide the toy at a totally new location, location B. You make the baby wait three seconds, and then let them search.
And almost every eight to 10 month old will confidently reach right back to location A, even though they literally just watched you put it in location B. This is weird. It's a hallmark cognitive error of that age. They simply don't yet understand that
objects persist in space independently of their own previous motor actions. They associate the toy with the physical habit of reaching to location A.
Right. but magically by 12 months old they stop making this error they can find the toy at b so the obvious assumption is that their brain simply matured like the hardware upgraded the software got patched and now they understand object
permanence
but that's not what happens what else happens between 8 and 12 months they learn to
trawl
exactly they learn to physically crawl and to prove that it's the physical crawling that updates the cognitive software Researchers took those eight-month-old babies who could not crawl yet and who were reliably failing the test and put them in mechanical baby walkers.
Just gave them wheels, basically.
Yeah. They artificially gave them the physical ability to self-locomote around the room months before they naturally would.
And suddenly, the baby stopped making the A-not beer just by putting them in a walker. But how? How does rolling around in a mechanical seat update your understanding of object permanence?
Because crawling isn't just leg movement. It fundamentally changes the physics of your sensory world. When you are carried by a parent, you are a passive observer of space. But when you move yourself, going around a couch, bumping into a coffee table, retreating from a
dog, you force your brain to constantly calculate distance.
You're doing the driving.
Right. You experience optic flow. You track objects as they enter and leave your visual field. Your active physical movement forces your brain to realize, oh, that couch is still there even when I crawl behind the chair. Your physical movement alters your cognitive understanding
of space.
And it goes beyond just realizing objects exist. We literally offload our intelligence into the physical environment itself. Like, we treat the three-dimensional world like an external hard drive. There's a brilliant study in the paper by Baldwin called the DAX task.
You sit a toddler down, maybe an 18-month-old. You hide one completely novel object in a bucket on their left and another novel object in a bucket on their right. You look directly into the bucket on the left without showing the child what's inside, and you say, hmm, I see a Dax in
here. You wait a bit, then pull both objects out, set them on the table, and ask the child, which one is a Dax?
And the child reliably points to the object that was in the left bucket. Now think about the cognitive math here. The auditory word DAX and the visual object were never present at the same time. Never. But the child easily solves this mystery by linking the new word to the physical
spatial location. They use the empty bucket on the left as a physical pointer for a memory.
And before you think this is just a weird toddler trick, adults do this constantly. The paper mentions the Hollywood Squares Eye Tracking Study. If you watch a screen where different facts are presented in different physical quadrants, and later someone asks you to
recall one of those facts, your eyes will involuntarily flick to the empty physical space where that fact used to be on the screen.
It's so automatic.
It is. Next time you try to recall a spreadsheet in a meeting, pay attention to your eyes. You'll probably stare at a blank piece of wall or a spot on the desk where your monitor usually sits.
we look at empty space to retrieve internal data from an embodied cognition standpoint you really can't separate the thinking from the spatial environment the physical world acts as the binding agent that connects our disparate thoughts together without those physical pointers acting
as spatial file folders the internal cognitive load on the brain would be overwhelming
but wait If we offload our memory into physical space, is learning actually impossible without a physical environment to point at? I mean, a baby still needs to know how to save and open those files without a user manual. They don't have instructions on how to use their
own bodies to access the world, so how do they figure it out?
they have to generate their own data. What's fascinating here is that to build true, flexible intelligence, you absolutely require non-goal-directed action, what we commonly call play.
Or chaos.
Yeah, more accurately in the case of a baby, creating absolute unfiltered chaos.
Chaos is the perfect word. The paper tracks this by following four different babies over three months as they simply try to learn how to reach out and grab a dangling toy. And what's striking is that they all started with completely different physical baselines.
Which is so important to note.
Right. One baby was a total flailer, just high energy, arms wildly flapping everywhere, constantly in motion. Another was a placid baby, low motor tone, arms resting quietly by her sides, barely fighting gravity.
This is a vital observation because it proves there is no universal pre-programmed reaching algorithm stored in the brain that a baby just boots up at month four. They
aren't robots.
No. The flailer and the placid baby had totally different physics problems to solve. The flailing baby had to learn how to dampen their kinetic energy, pull their arms inward, and focus. The placid baby had to learn to exert massive
energy over kind gravity and push outward.
They didn't have a plan. They just got excited by the visual of the toy. And they started moving their bodies randomly. They generated chaos. And eventually, by pure chance, the flailer's wildly swinging hand smacked the toy. And the placid baby's hand brushed it during
a rare exertion. And those tiny moments of accidental chaotic contact provided the exact multimodal feedback needed to carve out a successful reaching pattern over the next few weeks.
It's the exact same mechanism at work in the famous infant conjugate reinforcement experiment. This is the classic setup where researchers lay a baby on their back in a crib and tie a soft ribbon from their ankle to a mobile hanging overhead.
Oh, I've seen videos of this. At first, the baby is just doing standard random baby kicks. But because of the ribbon, the mobile shakes. You can almost see the cognitive gears lock into place. The baby realizes that when they kick, the world moves. And
suddenly they are kicking with absolute fury, testing the physical limits of this new power, laughing and flailing.
Yeah, it's wild to watch.
But wait, let me push back on this. Is kicking a mobile really a pillar of cognitive development? Isn't it just a baby exercising its leg muscles and getting overstimulated by a toy? I mean, is it really that deep?
It looks like exercise, sure, but it is literally the scientific method in action. The baby is generating complex, non-repeating events that are perfectly time-locked to their own motor actions. They are discovering cause and effect from pure randomness.
So it's the scientific process of discovering cause and effect from pure randomness.
Exactly. If that baby didn't have that initial period of spontaneous, seemingly useless movement, that open-ended floundering, there would be no data for the brain to learn from. Intelligence requires this kind of aimless exploration to stumble into new
problems and then discover new solutions.
Okay, so a baby kicking a mobile is learning physics and cause and effect. That makes sense for an isolated baby in a toy. But the real world isn't an empty room with a plastic mobile. What happens when you add other human beings into the mix?
Because interacting with a person has to change the equation.
It changes everything. This moves us from purely physical embodiment to social embodiment. When a baby smiles or coos or flails their arms at a caregiver, that caregiver acts just like a hyper-responsive mobile. Right. The baby vocalizes. The
parent immediately vocalizes back. It creates a tightly coupled, time-locked feedback loop.
But unlike a piece of plastic hanging over a crib, a parent adds a massive layer of scaffolding.
Precisely. A caregiver doesn't just statically mirror the baby. They instinctively elevate the interaction. They take the baby's chaotic natural rhythms of excitement and calm, and they weave them into a structured conversation. They imitate the baby's
vocalizations, which highlights and strengthens certain phones.
They're guiding them.
The parent acts as an editor, naturally selecting the chaotic patterns they find meaningful and reinforcing them.
There's an amazing observation in the paper by Yoshida and Smith that illustrates this perfectly. They watched parents talking to young kids while playing with a toy tape measure.
Oh, I love this example.
It's so good. The parents weren't just narrating what they were doing. They were entirely synchronizing the physical properties of their voices to the physical action of the toy. They would pull the tape measure out and say, see, you pull it, dragging the vowel out to match the exact
physical length of the tape. And when it snapped back in, they'd say, turn it round and round and round, matching the staccato rhythm of the spinning reel.
This is a masterclass in how social partners provide the multimodal support needed to ground language. The parent is capturing the child's attention and rhythmically binding the physical action, the visual object, and the auditory word together into one
tightly wrapped cognitive package.
Which perfectly sets up the final and perhaps most profound shift in this entire framework, which is learning a language. Because language takes all this messy physical sensory stuff we've been talking about and introduces a completely
alien concept.
The arbitrary symbol. Yes. And we really need to pause and appreciate how weird language is. It is powerful precisely because it is arbitrary. Think about the word dog. The auditory sound of the word dog looks absolutely nothing like a physical dog.
Right. It doesn't bark. It isn't furry.
Exactly. And the word dig sounds almost identical to dog, but the physical actions they represent couldn't be more different. You might think, wouldn't it be immensely easier for a developing baby if language was more like a pantomime, where the symbol physically resembled the thing it
represents?
Logically, you would think yes, like make it easier for the kid. But the paper shows that too much similarity actually shatters a child's ability to learn what a symbol even is.
Yeah, there is a wild study by Judy Deloach involving two-year-olds in a hiding game. You bring a toddler into a real full-sized room and you hide a toy, say, under the couch. Then you take them out and you show the child a scale model of that room
to communicate where the toy is hidden.
Okay, makes sense.
And here is the incredibly counterintuitive finding. If you make that scale model incredibly realistic, highly detailed couch, matching wallpaper, exact fabric textures... The two-year-old completely fails the task. They cannot figure out where the toy
is in the real room.
That is mind-blowing. Why would a more accurate map cause them to fail?
But if you show them a really basic, simplified model or even just a crude line drawing, they succeed effortlessly.
Seriously. Why?
Because to understand what a symbol is, it needs to have a distinct, unbreachable boundary from physical reality. If the scale model is too lifelike, the child's embodied brain just treats it as another physical object to interact
with and play with.
Oh, they just try to play with it. Yeah,
they try to sit on the tiny couch. Yeah. They lose the connection that it is merely a pointer to something else. The arbitrary nature of language, the fact that words do not look, sound, or feel like the things they describe, is what gives language its
unbelievable computational power.
The paper refers to this concept as orthogonality, right? Which essentially means they operate at right angles to each other. They don't overlap.
Exactly. Because words are arbitrary, they can take deeply overlapping physical concepts and pull them apart. Imagine you have a red rubber ball, a red apple, and a round red wooden block. Perceptually... Physically, they are incredibly similar. They are all
round. They are all red. They all fit in a hand. If we only thought in physical terms, they would blur together. But by assigning them completely different, entirely arbitrary labels, ball, apple, block, we force the brain to categorize them as
distinct entities.
And kids enforce this rule with ruthless efficiency. There is a phenomenon called the mutual exclusivity constraint. If you show a kid a highly familiar object, like a ball, and next to it you place a totally weird, spiky, bizarre object they've never seen before, and you
say, hey, hand me the DAX.
They know exactly what to do.
The kid doesn't hesitate. They know ball is already taken and has a label. Therefore, the weird new object must be the DAX.
It's a very rigid rule for them.
So if I'm following this whole lineage, language acts as a clean, untangled label for a remarkably messy, multimodal physical experience. It's exactly like slapping a simple, scannable barcode on a deeply complex, heavy physical package.
That is precisely what it is doing. And once you have those clean barcodes, you can start mentally rearranging them without having to lug the heavy physical packages around in your head.
That makes so much sense.
That is what grammar is. That is what planning for the future is. That is abstract thought. But it only works, it only makes sense, because that arbitrary symbol system is securely layered on top of a deeply physical embodied understanding of the three-dimensional
world.
So what does this all mean? If you are listening to this right now and you've ever felt completely overwhelmed trying to learn a new skill just by reading a dense PDF manual or staring passively at a tutorial go on a screen, I want you to give yourself some grace.
Because your biological hardware simply wasn't built for that kind of disembodied data transfer. You are fundamentally a physical thinker. You learn best by moving your hands, by manipulating objects, by linking your senses together, and by using the physical space around
you as your own personal whiteboard.
And if we take a step back and look at the massive implications of this paper, this embodied view of development raises a fiercely provocative question about the future of our own technology. How so? Well, right now, humanity is pouring hundreds of billions of dollars into training
artificial intelligence. We feed these vast neural networks all the text on the Internet, locking them inside silent, dark, sterile server racks.
Right. Totally disembodied.
But if human intelligence fundamentally requires starting small, blundering physically through space, feeling the weight of gravity, experiencing time-locked sensory overlap, and being guided by a physically responsive social partner, will an AI
completely devoid of a body ever truly replicate the inventive, flexible, open-ended intelligence of a human being? Or will it always just be a highly sophisticated calculator forever missing the very thinker itself, the body?